i hate intros attack out tie the final
season part one e episode one we kicked
things off in the middle of a war where
a boy named falco is nearly killed
luckily his older brother named colt had
found him laying on the ground and drug
him to safety back in the trenches once
he's back in the trenches he meets three
other kids who bring him up to speed on
everything going on the marlin empire
has been at war for four years and they
are in the process of trying to put an
end to it they will do this by taking
fort slava and sinking the middle
eastern federation's fleet in the port
behind it falco and the other kids are
warrior candidates and being put on the
front lines they were put there as a
part of a test to see which one of them
deserves to take on the armored titan
power once they decide who's gonna
inherit the power they will then take
part in an upcoming operation to
subjugate paradise island one of the
children gabby is pretty convinced that
she will be the one to inherit the power
and doesn't think anybody else is fit
for the job she wants to wipe out
everybody on paradise island so that she
can free all of the aldians in the
internme zones udo and zofia are the
other two candidates in the running but
they're not quite as confident as gabby
colt is trying to convince their captain
named maggot that they can't break
through the machine guns to get to the
railroads and destroy them which is
their ultimate goal the federation had
designed new armor-piercing weapons to
fight against the titans with these
weapons in place they fear deploying the
titans because they can't afford to lose
any more since maggeth and the marlin
government don't really care about
aldens that much they decide to
sacrifice 800 ldn soldiers to get the
job done debbie then convinces maggit to
let her go and try and destroy the
railroads by herself with seven
explosives she has she strips her
uniform off and then approaches the
enemy with explosives dragging on her
ankle the soldiers contemplate shooting
her but don't decide fast enough and so
she throws the explosives and destroys
the armored train with that part of the
plan successful they then prepare to
send zeke and reiner into fight they
airdrop in a bunch of aldean captives
and transform them into titans as
they're falling this acts as a scuff
bombardment on the fort allowing reiner
to penetrate the defenses a flight
ensues inside the fort where reiner is
nearly killed but they managed to take
out all the remaining defenses with the
fort now in their control the beast
titan lands and grabs a bunch of
explosive barrels hurling it towards the
fleet and destroying it
now that the middle eastern federation
has lost their fleet they are forced to
sign a peace treaty with marley
episode two even though they were
victorious in the battle it came with a
realization that their titans aren't
invincible and that mankind is catching
up in their weapons to fight them in
response to this zeke suggests that they
need to resume their campaign against
paradise island by doing this they could
send a message to the world that they
have reclaimed all of the titan powers
keeping them in line we also learned
that this is zeke's last year in his 13
years with the beast titan power once
the 13th year is up he will die due to
the curse of your mirror and he wants to
spend his last year seeing things
through on paradise island after that
falco's older brother colt will inherit
the beast's titan power and take on his
legacy we then hop on over to reiner who
talks with a new character in the name
of galliard galliard had gotten the jaw
titan power from yumir meaning that she
volunteered to be killed in order to
pass along the power another new
character joins the conversation in piek
who is also the wielder of the kart
titan but nothing really comes of that
now that the war is over all of the ldn
soldiers return to their internment
camps and families while eating with the
family we see that gabby is kind of
being brainwashed everyone is under the
impression that all the people on
paradise island are demons and savages
and deserve to die ryan are kind of
bandwagons on this sentiment and doesn't
bother to tell them what they're really
like in the last couple of scenes zeke
holds a meeting with the other warriors
they discuss that there's going to be a
festival and they want to have the
tibber family help them the tipper
family controls the warhammer titan and
fought king freaks during the great
titan war the family's words carry
weight so they want them to tell the
world that marlei will conquer paradise
island within one year episode three
we'd get a flashback if when reiner was
a kid his mother told him that she had
aldi and blood while his father had
marlene blood so they couldn't be
together he figured that if he could
become a marlene he could get his family
back together so that's why he joined
the warriors during their training we
see that porco and reiner never saw eye
to eye because they were both competing
for the armored titan position while the
kids are a part of a parade reiner sees
his father in the crowd so he goes to
confront him he eagerly tells his father
that him and his mom are now honorary
marlenes his father doesn't exactly
respond well because he says that if
they find out he's the father then he's
gonna be killed so he has to flee but
anyways hop on up to where the kids go
to paradise island to attack and
infiltrate the walls on the way there we
find out that porco's brother marcel had
gone behind everybody's back to ensure
that reiner got the armor titan power
instead of his brother this is because
he wanted to ensure porco's safety and
if he took on the titan power then it's
likely he would die during their talk
kumira surprises them and kills marcel
which is how she came into possession of
the jaw titan power and he blames reiner
from marcel's death and wants to take
him back to marley to be punished she
kicks the [ __ ] [ __ ] out of him but
eventually he convinces her that if they
all go back as failures though likely be
killed also this convinces them to carry
out the mission so they attack the walls
like in season 1 episode 1 and
infiltrate the city five years after
infiltrating the walls they were still
convinced that the marlins wouldn't be
happy with just information so they
decide that they need to destroy wall
rose this would force the founding titan
out of hiding and the marlenes could
finally seize control of it hop on over
to falco who meets with a man that he
had helped out named krueger the man was
claiming that he was suffering from ptsd
and staying at a hospital but in reality
he was just too scared to go home in the
last couple of scenes they both get to
talking and falco expresses that he
doesn't want gabby to take on the
armored titan power episode 4 kruger
doesn't want everybody to find out that
he's faking so he asks falco to mail
something for him it's a letter to his
family saying that he's at the hospital
and he's doing okay the next day the
tibber family arrive for the festival we
then meet the head of the tibber family
named willy we also learned that the
country of marley is actually ran by the
timber family jump ahead a bit where for
the first time falco beats gabby in a
race everybody celebrates because it
looks like he's actually putting up a
fight for the armored time position he
admits that he's fighting so hard
because he cares about gabby but she
doesn't really get the sentiment later
on krueger is approached by a doctor
saying not to involve falco with him
faking his ptsd so that he doesn't get
in trouble after the two talk for a bit
it's revealed that the doctor's name is
jaeger and it's actually gracious father
he has a meltdown when he starts
thinking about how grisha's sister and
his daughter was killed by the guards
and is taken off by some of his
colleagues falco and the other kids are
then tasked with serving drinks at a
party while serving the drinks udo makes
a mistake and spills wine on one of the
guests because he's an aldi and he's
going to get a lot of [ __ ] for this and
she knows this so she covers for him
saying that she spilt the wine instead
willie makes a speech saying that he's
found a solution to the ldn problem and
that tomorrow he's gonna reveal it on
stage the next day the festival starts
and we get a quick compilation of all of
the kids enjoying their time at the
festival before inevitably everything is
going to [ __ ] fall apart episode 5.
we come in on a conversation where we
learn that kruger and reiner seem to
have some sort of pass together while
they're talking we see that everybody
has gathered together to see this
performance this includes the heart of
the marlene army ambassadors and famous
families from all over the world krueger
is revealed to be aaron in disguise and
reiner recognized him right away the
performance gets underway where willie
tells the story of the marlene history
porco and piac are led by one of the
soldiers where they wind up falling into
a trap willie then switches gears and
tells how the history actually unfolded
king fruits had came to regret the
aldian empire savage history he also
hated that the marlenes were living in
oppression when he inherited the
founding titan power him and the tipper
family devised a plan they wanted to
establish a savior figure which is how
the hero helus was born the real reason
he retreated to paradise island was
because he had renounced war altogether
this sentiment was passed down to
everybody who inherited the founding
titan power which is why none of them
wanted to fight the war he also reveals
that the tipper family had bargained for
their family's continued safety they
joined hands with carl freitz and sold
eldia to marley over to pierre camportco
who can't transform because it's too
small of a space the letters that aaron
had sent with falco were actually going
to his family but they were going to his
allies aaron finally confronts reiner
about how his mother was killed and
asked for an explanation rioter goes on
to tell him that they were trying to get
to the founding titan power and that she
was basically just collateral aaron
realizes that he can't completely blame
reiner for all of the things that they
did because he was so heavily influenced
as a kid as willie's speech is coming to
an end he declares war on paradise
island kind of a bad [ __ ] idea
because in the last couple of scenes
aaron takes on his titan form and kills
willie
episode 6. we see that earlier that day
maggot and willie had discussed the
possibility of there being an attack at
the performance their performance was
actually to get all of the marlene
officers together and use them as bait
to lure out the enemy aaron locates
where all the officers are sitting and
rushes them killing them all
after that willy's sister who holds the
warhammer titan power transforms aaron
quickly reacts and lays a [ __ ] out
the warhammer titan soon fights back
against aaron impaling in we see that
udo is being carried by cult and was
badly injured and all of the commotion
piek didn't trust the soldier leading
them so she managed to tip off other
soldiers that go and find them aaron
starts losing the fight against the
warhammer titan as well as taking heavy
shots from the antsy titan cannons he
gets his ass handed to him and just as
he's about to get killed mikasa jumps in
to save him the other scouts are also
there in launch attacks taking out the
anti-titan cannons aaron realizes that
the warhammer titan can use hardening to
make whatever weapon it wants this means
that it won't die even if you destroy
the nape of its neck because of all of
its neat little abilities aaron wants to
use this opportunity to eat the
warhammer titan meanwhile we see that
udo didn't get to the doctor in time and
wound up dying gabby's pretty pissed and
wants to get involved in the fighting
but when she tries to two soldiers get
killed by sasha in front of her which
pisses her off even more back over to
the fight with the warhammer titan where
aaron had noticed that it had
materialized from the ground at the
center of the stage aaron finds her real
body and is about to eat it but then
porco shows up and tries eating him
luckily mikasa cuts to the titan's jaw
preventing him from being able to bite
down onto aaron in the last couple of
scenes porco is prevented from fling and
swarmed by the paradise soldiers
episode 7
as the scouts are charging pack shows up
in her titan opening fire on them and
deterring them from killing porco zeke
shows up in the beast titan to reinforce
lamar lane segwaying into a battle
between the two sides aaron's titan is
pretty [ __ ] up but he's gained a lot
of stamina since the last season so he
can transform again as marlene warships
arrive to help in the fight we see that
armin is actually in the middle of the
fleet on a fishing boat he transforms
into the colossal titan destroying all
of the ships in a massive blast while
everyone is distracted by the blast levi
capitalizes by catching zekov guard
cutting the nape of his titan's neck
once he's down levi blows his neck up
with a grenade seemingly killing zeke in
the process over to sasha and jon along
with other scouts who blow up the kart
titan severely injuring piac in the
process porco catches aaron off guard
attacking him with his jaw tight and
making aaron realize how strong his jaw
actually is jumping all over the [ __ ]
place at this point hanji then shows up
in an airship as a means to extract all
of the scouts out of the battlefield
back over to porku who gets his arms
ripped off by aaron and then he uses his
powerful jaw to break through the case
protecting lara the case breaks open
killing her in the process and spilling
her blood into aaron's mouth giving him
the warhammer titan's power porco is
next on the menu but then gabby starts
calling out to the unconscious rider to
save him reiner hears the calls and
despite wanting to just die in peace he
decides to take on his titan form once
again to save porco episode 8 aaron and
reiner have their fight which doesn't
last too long because aaron knocks him
out with one punch but he manages to get
porco to safety in the process now that
they've gotten a hold of aaron which was
their main objective all of the
remaining scouts aboard the airship to
make their escape gabby is distraught
because sophia was crushed by debris and
udo was trampled by the crowd while
trying to save her she is determined to
exact revenge on the scout so she chases
after the airship shooting and killing
one of the scouts his body falls to the
ground but his maneuver gear is still
attached to the ship since she wants to
kill all of the scouts she uses the gear
to get onto the ship and falco wants to
keep her safe so he is forced to tag
along once they had boarded the ship
gabby busts in does a sick combat roll
and then shoots sasha which she will
later die from she nearly shoots jon
also but falco tackles her preventing
the shot from landing once the scouts
register what's actually happening they
rush the kids and start beating the [ __ ]
out of them the kids are then subdued
and brought in where they find zeke
who's actually alive and aboard the ship
also turns out that he had faked his
death because he's actually working with
the scouts it's not just him though
because one of his loyal soldiers elena
had worked together with him to conspire
against the marlins hodge then reveals
that this operation wasn't planned and
aaron forced the scouts into action by
getting himself captured they can't
afford to lose him so they had no choice
but to launch an attack and get him back
aaron is arrested for breaking their
trust forcing them into the situation
and ultimately getting sasha killed in
the process
episode 9. now we hop back three years
to where a marlin ship and its crew are
captured by aaron and the scouts elena
was on board the ship which is how she
came to meet everybody hanji
investigates their weapons while elena
tells them about the marlene forces
since they're so powerful hanji wants to
figure out why they haven't attacked yet
the first reason are the pure titans
that are on paradise island originally
the pure titans were set loose onto the
island by the marlenes to keep the
aldians trapped inside the walls but
ironically they wound up just making it
difficult to invade the island later the
second reason is that marlei is at war
with other countries and can't afford to
focus on paradise island right now
before they were captured elena and the
other soldiers shot their superior
officers on zeke's orders she and the
other soldiers on board had their
homelands invaded by marley before being
forced to join the army because they're
not exactly fans of marley their goal is
the liberation of all aldeans from the
marlene oppressors these soldiers will
become known as the anti-marlian
volunteers they also say that zeke's
goal from the beginning has always been
to gain control of the founding titan
power of course in the prior seasons he
had tried using force to obtain the
power but since that didn't exactly pan
out now he's having to work with the
scouts to get it he claims to have some
sort of plan to resolve all of ld's
problems but he's not going to say what
it is until he has control of the
founding titan power along with the
titan of royal blood with the help of
the anti-marlin volunteers they learn
about the outside world and advance
their technology to fight against them
we also see that one of the marlenes
named nicolo had cooked for sasha while
he was there and was pretty sad about
her death because there was something
going on between the two of them
episode 10 back into the past again two
years before the battle in marley a port
was constructed on paradise island and
they received their first foreign
dignitary the ship is from hizuru which
is the only nation friendly to paradise
island on board is kyomi azumabito who
is the lady that prevented udo from
getting beaten at the party after he
accidentally spilled some wine on her
turns out that their emblem has been
passed down through mikasa's mother's
side of the family but she never knew
what it meant the lady tells mikasa that
the son of a shogun chose to remain on
paradise island as a sign of friendship
with king freitas hizuru then lost its
standing after being defeated in the
great titan war this means that mikasa
is the lost descendant to their
country's ruler zig candy zero had met
in private before where he gave her the
3d maneuver gear that he got from
paradise island he also says that the
fuel it runs on is called iceburg stone
and has never been discovered outside of
the island in exchange for participating
in his plan to get the founding titan
power he promises them to revitalize
their industrial sector returning the
nation to its former glory kiyomi came
to meet with them to utilize their
natural resources and make a profit they
plan on becoming a political power with
the help of hizuru using the rumbling to
keep the other nations from attacking
them the rumbling is a last resort which
entails using the founding titan power
to wake up all the colossal titans that
are lying dormant inside the walls this
would be devastating to anybody caught
in the titans path so they are hoping
that the threat of it will be enough
without them actually having to use it
because zeke doesn't have much time to
live they need to ensure that the beast
titan is passed down historia agrees to
take on the beast titan's power when the
time comes aaron isn't happy with this
plan and conveys his dismay during the
meeting but anyways back got up to the
present where we see that historia had
messed around a little bit and gotten
pregnant in the process the father of
the child used to throw rocks at astoria
when she was younger which is so
romantic but he felt guilty about this
as he grew up so to make amends he
helped the orphanage where she had grown
up when she found out about this she
apparently got kind of hot and bothered
and they [ __ ] now that she's pregnant
though they can't turn her into a titan
so that she can eat zeke and take on the
beast titan's power because they fear
that the baby might be killed in the
process episode 11 gabby goes for an
oscar feigning some sort of mental
breakdown then beats the guard to death
with a wooden block her and falco then
make a run for it escaping from their
holding cells because apparently there's
one [ __ ] guard gabby is looking for
zeke because she's determined to get
some answers from him before they're
found the two of them then come across a
girl named kaya and she brings them back
to her house where they are fed by the
family there meanwhile kiomi comes back
to the island and reveals that with the
help of the iceberg stone they made the
first flying ship now we jump on over to
flock who had told the press about aaron
being arrested this was an attempt to
get aaron set free but instead him and
the others are put on trial for leaking
information pixies is suspicious that
elena was responsible for helping aaron
act on his own so he goes to
interrogator meanwhile we see falco and
gabby are helping kaia do some chores
around the place kaya had overheard them
talking and figured out that they're
marlene's the three of them get to
talking and it's revealed that kaya is
the girl sasha had saved in the earlier
seasons from a titan and the family
she's living with are sasha's parents
kaya tells him that the family was
invited to eat with nicolo so if they
come along maybe they can find a way
back to marley because nicolo is marlene
also episode 12. now that the press has
found out about aaron being detained
people gather outside the headquarters
to protest for him to be released
meanwhile elena expresses that she did
meet with aaron and told him that a fire
needed to be lit under the military but
he did way more than she was hoping for
over to zachary who meets with mikasa
and army to tell them that it's likely
aaron has been influenced by zeke during
his time alone in marley after their
talk armin speculates that the military
has given up on aaron and they're
looking for someone to inherit the titan
powers he possesses mikasa then wants to
eavesdrop on zachary's next meeting but
then his office is blown up and zachary
is killed in the explosion he had a
custom chair brought in and the
explosives were installed inside of it
armin recalls that the chair was brought
in by survey corps recruits and he
remembers seeing one of them leaving the
headquarters after their talk their
meeting is then interrupted when they
find out that aaron had escaped from his
underground cell he then goes to meet
with flock and other scouts who are
loyal to him these scouts have spies
inside the military and are the ones
responsible for killing zachary this is
because they were planning on killing
aaron to transfer the titan powers so
they just wanted to protect him aaron
and the scouts loyal to him are referred
to as jaegerus and their goal is to have
aaron make contact with zeke so he can
use the founding titan power now that
zachary is gone pixie starts calling the
shots and he suggests that they open
negotiations with the yeagers this is
controversial of course but he explains
that they don't have time to be fighting
amongst themselves about these things
hanji wants to investigate all of the
work environments elena established for
captain marlene's including the
restaurant where gabby and falco are
brought for their meal and in the last
couple of scenes we also see that piak
has made her way onto the island
episode 13. we come in on an explanation
as to why the titans from ragako village
which was connie's village followed the
beast heinz commands zeke's spinal fluid
is capable of turning people into titans
so they weaponized his spinal fluid into
a gas that was released into the village
people who inhaled the gas remain
paralyzed until zeke sends an order
through the paths and the power of the
titans is sent to their coordinates
gabby and falco go with kaio's family to
meet nicolo who wanted to cook for them
because they were sasha's parents and he
was in love with her [ __ ] shows up with
some others to ask nicolas some
questions but agreed to wait until he's
finished cooking for the family once
nicolo is off by himself gabby and falco
make their move to ask him for help
since he's a marlene gabby reveals to
him that she was the one who shot sasha
thinking that he's a marlene who hates
the aldians also when he hears that she
was the one who killed the girl he was
in love with he loses control and
attacks them grabbing a bottle of wine
he hits falco over the head with it and
then beats the [ __ ] out of gabby after
that he drags him up to sasha's family
to have the father execute the killer of
his daughter hanji and the others hear
the commotion and rush in to try and
de-escalate the situation sasha's father
refuses though saying that he wants to
be the one who breaks the cycle of
killing everything seems like it's going
to be fine until kaya of all people
rushes gabby and nearly kills her with a
knife but is stopped at the last second
that should have been the end of it but
then it's revealed that some of the wine
that went into falco's mouth when he was
hit contained some of zeke's spinal
fluid nicolo is a hundred percent sure
that the spinal fluid is in there but he
has a hunch that's the case elena was
urging him to give the wine to the
higher ranking military members but it's
likely she was the only one who knew
about it while talking with gabby aaron
suddenly appears and jaegers take over
the building flock apparently knew about
the spinal fluid being inside the wine
which means that this is all a part of
their plan andy takes hanji along with
the others captive and in the last
couple of scenes aaron mikasa armin and
gabby sit down for a little talk episode
14. aaron starts out by saying that he's
free and acting independently from any
influence meaning that zeke isn't
forcing him to do this well in marley
aaron went to talk with zeke by himself
and learn more about the titan's powers
he then points out that armin has been
going to visit annie so much because
part of beritold is living on inside of
him and he was in love with annie as for
mikasa he tells her that the ackerman
family was formed to protect the king of
eldia when aaron had ordered her to
fight against the men that killed her
parents when she was a kid her instincts
were awakened now he suggests that she
only exists to follow orders he insults
her saying that she's a slave and people
who aren't free make him sick so he
can't stand the sight of her when he
says that he hates her armin loses his
cool and tries to attack him but mikasa
reacts without thinking and subdues army
aaron uses this as proof that she is a
slave to obey her ackermann blood armin
is then let free so he attacks aaron but
the fight is pretty one-sided obviously
because army is a bit of a [ __ ] so he
gets the [ __ ] kicked out of him after
that aaron says that he's going to meet
zeke and shigashina and he is taking
gabby with him over to levi who decides
that he wants to give ziggs beast titan
to someone else as he prepares to attack
him zeke suddenly makes a run for it and
screams out the soldiers there had been
drinking the wine with zeke's spinal
fluid in it so when he lets out his
scream all of the soldiers transform
into titans levi doesn't feel quite
right killing the titans because they
were his men but come on he's a little
bit too alpha for that so he does it
anyways and then catches up to zeke zeke
is forced to transform and the two of
them get into a little bit of a skirmish
that ends with levi using thunder spears
to blow zeke out of his titan oddly
enough he survives but is badly injured
and unable to fight back so levi drags
him along with him meanwhile in chicago
luck and the icarus take over keith's
training flock convinces some of the men
to join the igarus and then they beat
the [ __ ] out of keith to prove their
loyalty back over to levi where zeke has
regained consciousness so levi cuts off
his arms and legs so he can't transform
episode 15. we come in on a flashback of
zeke growing up his family and him are
discriminated against because their
eldians and his father tries to instill
his values in zeke saying that it's not
okay they're treated this way and they
need to change the world zeke enters his
warrior training where he falls behind
and catches the eye of tom xaver who is
the current beast titan at the time we
also say that he is frequently brought
to his grandparents house where he
learns about the marlene history his
grandparents tried to teach him the
marlene version and believe in atoning
for what the audience had supposedly
done in contrast his father grisha would
teach him the marlene stories are lies
fabricated as propaganda but anyway zeke
is still struggling in his training and
underperforming compared to the other
kids one day while walking home he winds
up playing catch with tom when he gets
home he overhears grecia saying that
with how bad his grades are the owl
can't manipulate the selection process
for zeke to become a warrior he keeps
trying but still can't keep up with the
others and his father is pissed because
her plan is relying on him he plays
catch with tom again and finds out that
tom had only become a warrior for his
research and titans tom tells zeke that
it started when the founder came into
contact with something and he wants to
learn what happened while walking around
he overhears a meeting where marlene
soldiers expose that they know about the
aldean restorationists and the owl
working as the informant of the group he
tries talking his parents out of being
in the movement but they are set on
their plan and he can't convince them
otherwise 2020 hindsight you probably
should have just [ __ ] told them that
they were gonna be captured but you know
whatever zeke goes to tom for advice and
tells him about his parents being
restorationist tom is the one who
convinced zeke to turn in his parents in
order to keep zeke and his grandparents
safe now we jump ahead to when he's a
little bit older and tom's getting close
to the end of his time as the beast
titan in his research tom learned that
not only can the founding titan power
manipulate memories but it can also
alter the structure of their bodies zeke
gets the idea to use this power to
prevent subjects of ymir from having
babies that way the titans would
disappear tom tells him to find the one
who holds the founding titan power and
then the beast heightened power is
passed on to zeke jump ahead just a bit
where aaron and zeke had their meeting
before the attack in marley zeke tells
him about the quote-unquote ld and
euthanasia plan and the two agree to
work together now we hop back on up to
the present where levi goes to cut off
zeke's legs again but a pin is pulled
and there's a massive explosion
episode 16. zeke just [ __ ] refuses to
die so he survives through this
explosion also and then the titan comes
over rips open its stomach and then puts
him inside like a goddamn tauntaun from
star wars elena and pixies have a talk
about how a lot of the military had
drank the spinal fluid already this
caused even more soldiers to join the
jaegers to avoid being turned into
titans white armbands are given to the
soldiers who are yeagerous red are for
those who converted after drinking the
wine and black are for the ones who
drank the wine but still refuse to join
we then see the anti marlene volunteers
come to see mikasa and the others while
talking griez who is relatively
unimportant up until this point starts
saying [ __ ] about nicolo who is locked
up there too it talks about how sasha
was a horror or whatever which is a tiny
bit rude so elena shoots him in the head
meanwhile aaron goes to meet with gabby
to ask her to work with him and in
exchange he will save falco piek who had
infiltrated the building then stabs one
of the guards and holds aaron at
gunpoint she then monologues about how
she became a warrior for her father's
medical treatment or whatever he cares
she says she wants to show her father a
bright future for the eldians so she
requests that aaron destroy marley
gabby's not too happy about hearing px
say this so pc has to clarify saying
that if they keep on this track
eventually marlei won't need them
anymore and they'll be killed so she
wants to prevent that from happening
aaron wants proof that she's going to
help them so she offers to take him to
the roof and point out where her allies
are back over to elena who goes into
more detail about zeke's euthanasia plan
and how he's going to use the founding
titan's power to alter the aldians
bodies in order to prevent them from
having kids they will use the threat of
the rumbling to keep the world at bay
until the eldians peacefully die out
army breaks down like a little [ __ ]
saying that this planet is so noble and
he's so overwhelmed yadda yadda yadda
elena meets with aaron on the roof and
warns that it's dangerous to trespieck
when piek is asked to point out the
enemy she points at aaron and then the
jaw titan breaks through the roof nearly
eating aaron in the process porco misses
his target though allowing aaron to take
on his titan form piak reassures gabby
that she is still loyal as marlene ships
appear above the city with reiner in tow
i'm gonna be doing the future seasons
and you can find that in the left side
whenever i'm finished with it or you can
check out all the attack on titan recaps
in the playlist on the right side you
can also find the links in the
description below and the only thing i
hate more than intros is outros